starting to rhyme
[Music]
laughs
Christian
s
foreign
[Music]
you do not have to be good
even the best of us have been
misunderstood
so get upon your feet
the sun is shining repentance through
the leaves
[Music]
foreign
all right
hello welcome to the table y'all how
about this weather
are y'all loving it
yeah it's great
it's awful like this is
um insufferable has been the best
description of this weather and I'm so
sorry and I pray for all of us
um welcome to the table I'm so glad
you're here whether this is your first
Sunday or your 7th hundred Sunday if
you're online if you're watching this on
a Tuesday
um welcome hello
um I have two announcements that I want
to share with you guys before we get
started with this gift of a service my
first announcement is in McKinney Texas
there is a Counseling Center called
sharp wellness and they are hosting an
event or they have an event that they
can host called under the queer umbrella
and that is geared towards family
members of lgbtq plus affirming
um teens family members who have
questions who have thoughts who want to
be guided in the direction of
understanding better and so for example
this class would be for the mom whose
child has said I am pansexual and the
mom is like well what does that mean I
want to love you well I want to
understand this
um this event would be geared towards
answering those questions in a safe
place am I is this on am I it is okay
it's my own ears
sorry
um this is geared towards those those
family members or friends who have
questions and want to ask them in a safe
and appropriate environment that is not
offensive or hurtful it's called under
the queer umbrella if you are interested
in this we need to gauge that to see if
this is an event that we would indeed
host in the fall where do you sign up
great question as you walk out this door
on a tiny little table there are these
cards with QR codes there's also one up
there and you can scan that and then
you'll find the appropriate place to
click under the queer umbrella yes I'm
interested and then we can talk about
hosting that here at Pleasant Valley my
second announcement is August 27th we
are hosting a welcome to the table class
and that's for anyone who is interested
in becoming a member or just has
questions and interested in the table
period and wants to understand more
that's from three to four Thirty Child
Care is provided and if you are
interested in that again on the tiny
table or scan this QR code and sign up
there so we have a general idea of who
would be coming to that welcome to the
table class
now
as we shift gears into worship I was
looking at the first song that they're
going to be leading Us in tonight and it
is full of some really really beautiful
imagery and I'm a person who loves a
good analogy and a good metaphor to
really understand something and
frequently I ask my husband I'm like can
you just like paint a picture of what
you're saying because I don't understand
what a terabyte in a gigabyte in a
kilobyte in an alligator bite is this
conversation literally happened this
week I'm like I need you to draw out the
graph show me what this means I don't I
still don't really understand so if
anyone has a good graph on that
appreciate it but this song is filled
with images of different relationships
that we have towards God in different
seasons and
um there are so many of these that are
applicable all throughout the day or
maybe one really stands out to you in
the particular season that you're in
right now and so I wanted to read
through some of those
um
together and to really sit with them and
maybe just pick which one is for you
tonight and to really dwell in and find
the peace and love of Jesus in that so
I'm just going to read them in the book
we can take a big Collective breath in
breath out
and I'm going to read those you can
close your eyes
and think through which which part of
God's love are you really needing to be
embraced by tonight or today or tomorrow
let the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run
the fountain I drink from
be the shadow where I hide the ransom
for my life be the wind inside my sails
the anchor in the waves
the fire inside my veins
the echo of my days
God we praise you
for being all these things to all people
in any given moment that you can be an
anchor that you can be wind that you can
be fire in our veins that you could be
the shadow that we hide in or the
mountain that we run to you are in all
things and your image is in us it's in
the mountains it's in the depths of the
sea and we praise you and I pray that we
would find you in those places and not
be afraid to show up in those places and
be embraced by your love God I pray over
everyone in this room
that wherever they are finding
themselves tonight
that peace that Joy
strength
courage and love would wash over them
that they would breathe in your presence
and your strengths and carry it into
another week of the highs and the lows
and maybe dwelling in one of these
places where uncomfortable but you are
there
maybe it's shaky but your presence is
felt maybe it's dark but your light is
shining help us to see it
help us to feel it and help us to guide
one another to those places of safety of
Tranquility of goodness
in Jesus name
thank you Kelly would you guys stand as
we sing those words together
and I just encourage you to root
yourself down into those lyrics
hey
[Music]
foreign
the key the king of my heart be the wind
inside my cells the anger in the waves
always
[Music]
[Applause]
you're good
oh
[Music]
my God
you're never gonna let Never Gonna Let
Me Down
You're Never Gonna Let Never Gonna Let
You're Never Gonna Never Gonna Let Me
Down
You're Never Gonna Let Never Gonna Let
Me Down
[Music]
You're Never Gonna Let never gonna let
me down now you're never gonna let
You're Never Gonna Let Me Down
yeah
I've never done
Never Gonna Let Me Down you are good
you're good
[Music]
oh you're never
you're never gonna let You're Never
Gonna Let Me Down
[Music]
you are good
you good
oh
you are good you're good
you're good oh
all right the kids are dismissed to go
to their classes Nursery is back there
in the back and we have four through
first grade in this classroom over here
to my left and then second through sixth
to my right
and thank you to all of our fabulous
kids ministry workers and helpers who
are loving on them teaching them about
the love of God
um we're really grateful to have a safe
space for our kids and I know that our
kids ministry is putting in a lot of
work right now to do training and make
sure that their team is
um really all on the same page with
moving forward and the best way to take
care of our kids and that requires so
much work and energy so just a big thank
you to those leaders who are stepping up
taking extra time that's just
um it means a lot to me as as a mom of
kids here at the table so thank you guys
um we're going to move into the prayers
of the people and Jenny Lee is going to
lead that tonight so you guys can read
aloud with her as she reads and then
there will be a break in the prayer
where you can offer up a name or a
situation that you're carrying on your
heart tonight and if you're online
you're welcome to leave that in the
comments
um and then we'll finish the prayer
together but I just encourage you guys
to enter this space wholeheartedly and
bring bring the heaviness or whatever it
is that you're carrying into this space
and and lift it up and share it with us
so that we can hold it before God
together
generally
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names in
situations up to you
thank you
dad
foreign
[Music]
s we have spoken aloud and for those we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
thank you
Christ is my firm foundation
The Rock on which I stand when
everything around me is shaking
I've never been more glad that I put my
faith in Jesus
cause he's never let me down he's
faithful through generation
[Music]
so I would he feel now he won't know
I've still got joy in chaos
I've got peace that makes no sense so I
won't be going
[Music]
[Applause]
and he's never let me down he's faithful
living
things
[Music]
we will face
you will face
you you won't feel
[Music]
good
Christ is
[Music]
[Applause]
and I put my faith in Jesus yeah
he's never let me down he's faithful
through
generations
so I would he fail now
[Music]
you all face
was built on you
and I'm safe with you I'm gonna make it
through sing that again
rain came with my
House was built on you
and I'm safe with
you I'm gonna make it through
[Music]
was built on you tonight
make it through
[Music]
cause my house is builts on you
I've been thinking this week a lot about
the word security
um
and just what it means what it looks
like
for us to live as secure people
and how it can change the way that we
interact with the environment around us
with the people in our households with
our co-workers
for a lot of you who are teachers or
First Responders for the people who are
looking to you for guidance what that
would change whenever we're living out
of security of being loved being known
being seen
and I love that last song because it
just reminds me
to think about what my Foundation is
what I'm building my life on
what I'm setting my roots into
and if it's anything outside of the love
of God
then what am I going to have to give
away what fruit is going to come out
and this next song is called palm of
your hand and we've done it a couple of
times
but it just kind of names that life can
be crazy
and and learning to walk in a life where
we are grounded where we where we know
that we are loved that can be
challenging it's not always easy
but
he is God and he has got us
we are his we are loved
so let's live into that truth into that
reality let that change us let it take a
root in our heart tonight
foreign
[Music]
trusting you
different ly
missed I know that all you've said
you've got it no it's not easy
go and trust in you
so I will stop and breathe best here in
your goodness
I
know you won't believe it's my
confidence
foreign
[Music]
trust in you
cause I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness
[Music]
foreign
not a lie inside my head not a fear or
offense nothing can take me away
[Music]
inside my head another fear or offense
nothing can take me away
[Music]
inside my head not a fear or a fence
nothing could take me away
or death and not a lie inside my head
not a fear or offense nothing could take
me away nothing can take me away nothing
can take me away nothing can take me
away
foreign
[Music]
nothing could take me away nothing could
take me away
here I am
here
[Music]
it's my confidence
foreign
[Music]
into the truth that nothing takes us
away from your love God
nothing in our past or our present
can remove us from the love of God
there's nothing in our story that you
don't already know
God I pray that we would live
into Psalm 139 that we are fearfully and
wonderfully made
and that we would know that full well
let us live from that knowledge
let it take root into our soul into our
lives and our homes
that you love us and we know that full
well
and let us love others from that place
in Jesus name
amen
would you guys turn and welcome the
people around you and then Brett will
get us started with the message
well Grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all so so
good my name is Brett and I want to
extend a warm welcome to each and every
one of you and as always that includes
those join us online y'all are not
forgotten
uh love you lots and um anywhere anyone
who's new thank you so much for being
with us I know um you can just be
nerve-wracking I don't know what it is
about coming into a church for the first
time it's like there's this sense of
like they're all best friends and I'm
not the best friend yet you know and
um even though of course there's like
people you know we have folks who've
been here three weeks and three months
and some three years
um so you know just know uh you can be
at ease we're really really glad that
you're here really glad
um so we are in um right in in kind of
the middle of a series right now A
settled the Book of James and uh we're
just kind of picking up on like certain
themes from this book of the New
Testament I chose it um each year I like
to do at least one series that's just
like on a book of the Bible
um and I was trained by Southern
Baptists although I myself am not
Southern Baptist um
I don't think they'd have me
um for sure I don't think but I still
have a little you know maybe there's
something in me that's like well we
should at least do one book of the Bible
you know I don't know there's nothing so
um I tend to do I guess New Testament
books since uh they tend to be shorter
and I can actually cover them in one
series you know
um so this year it's the Book of James
and uh this isn't great if you've never
read it it is great uh one of the it's
actually one of the earliest books
written in the entire New Testament uh
which kind of plays out interestingly
like you can kind of tell
um it's there's not like a ton of like
abstract theology going on you know this
is not the Gospel of John uh which is
written maybe you know 70 80 90 years
kind of after Christ's Resurrection
um
this isn't a letter written by Paul who
if you've read his stuff you know
actually there's a place in the book of
Peter I think where he talks about
Paul's writings and it's like this guy
he's tough to understand uh if you've
read the book of Romans you're like yeah
wow there's a lot going on here
um James is not like that James he's not
doing a lot of highfalutin theology he's
just like
um how are we living
that's kind of his thing and that's
really the um the message tonight uh is
very
um in line with that so it's titled an
action-oriented faith and uh our passage
is from James James chapter two uh
verses 14 through 19. uh where James
asks some really good questions he says
what good is it my brothers and sisters
if someone claims to have faith
but then has no Deeds right in other
words like actions can such Faith save
them suppose a brother or sister is
there without clothes and daily food if
one of you says to them go in peace keep
warm and well fed but does nothing about
their physical needs what good is it in
the same way Faith by itself if it is
not accompanied by action
is what
dead
but someone will say well you have faith
and I have Deeds well show me your faith
without deeds and I will show you my
faith by my Deeds you believe that there
is one God well good even the demons
believe that and shudder
we'll come back to some of those
interesting little insights in terms of
phrase later
um where I wanted to kind of set this up
is by actually
talking about starting by talking about
belief
um because clearly he's got kind of a
contrast going on he uses the word faith
indeed sort of which can get a little
tricky you know we use terms like Faith
trust belief kind of interchangeably and
that's partly because at times the
biblical writers will sort of do that
um
so
uh but let's kind of hone on this word
kind of belief uh you know from its
earliest days
Christianity partly because of its
nature so um I'm like far from some sort
of scholar of religion but if you guys
get my e-letters and many of you do you
know I'm like interested in other
religious Traditions or read them
um and I um I think even there's things
to learn there I don't feel I don't feel
like it's always like a combative
relationship between you know
Christianity and all of the Demonic
faiths of the world you know I think
actually there can be sort of demonic or
or like evil or bad beliefs in sort of
um all sorts of either you know
political ideologies religions
um but even the church in Christianity
isn't like somehow exempt before I mean
clearly we've had you know just look at
the churches in like World War II to use
the uh the overused example you know
that just go right along with Hitler you
know it's like well we can have our
moments you know
um so but you know the thing with like
other religious Traditions they aren't
quite like something about Judaism and
Christianity they are so gosh darn like
historical like clearly into the Bible
in this earliest chapters has some like
mythology going on at least I believe so
um sort of like mythology I'm thinking
of like stories that are so old and so
ancient whatever history is there has
probably long been lost and they clearly
have I don't know there's sort of
Fantastical elements to them you know
but by the time you get in the Bible to
I mean at the very least say like
um the like all of the famous Kings you
know King Solomon and King David and
King Saul and by that you've clearly I
mean we have like artifacts like actual
historical references to these people
outside the Bible so we're talking like
history right and I think probably even
before then history kicks in so that's
kind of different for a religious
tradition that is so rooted in like the
story you know not just the the
principle of a thing that's always been
true but like this thing happened in
these ways you know can you see where
that feeds into a religious tradition of
belief
right because you kind of have there
well these we well I mean thinking like
in a Christian context right we believe
in Jesus and that doesn't just mean some
sort of vague thing it's sort of like
the story you know the that that Christ
came Among Us and he he lived he um
taught he uh was crucified he was
resurrected and ascended right there's
like these sort of markers and so as
Christians like yes we believe in fact
there's a good um kind of summary of of
belief there's a few Creeds running
around that churches will read uh some
of them like every Sunday and um this
one's from the Apostles Creed this is
like a kind of a good I know short and
sweet summation of like you know the
beliefs uh so it goes like this I
believe this probably recognized this
for many of you will I believe in God
the Father Almighty creator of Heaven
and Earth I believe in Jesus Christ his
only son our Lord who was conceived by
the Holy Spirit and born of the Virgin
Mary suffered under Pontius Pilate was
crucified died and was buried
he descended to Hell the third day he
rose again from the dead he ascended to
heaven and is seated at the right hand
of God the Father Almighty from there he
will come to judge the living and the
dead I believe in the Holy Spirit the
Holy Catholic Church the communion of
saints the Forgiveness of sins the
resurrection of the body and the life
Everlasting amen right so you you can
kind of see where it's just like a
Punchy and like very I mean no he even
said like we believe I believe I believe
you know can you see where this is like
deep in Christian faith right this huge
emphasis on belief on faith
um now we could kind of try to contrast
that in ways I do think Jesus was
clearly very
um like action oriented
um but even he right this isn't somehow
like well it was just the the later
Christians screwed it all up but Jesus
he didn't care about that Faith or
belief stuff at all you know
[Music]
I was kind of into I'm thinking of like
the story um there's one from I mean I
could pick many but there's one from
like Mark nine
where a uh father he had this his young
son
who was struggling with
um all sorts of he the the father really
believed he was possessed by a demon
probably he would have these seizures
but the seizures would often happen in
ways that would try to end his life he
describes to Jesus how I was like would
throw him into fires and just in a way
where this this father just felt like oh
my gosh there's like something really
messed up and so he comes to Jesus um
you know this this wonder worker and
he's like please you know um
can you heal my son
and uh Jesus response is interesting he
says if you can believe
all things are possible to those who
believe
and I love the the man's response he
says Lord I believe
help my unbelief
in that honest
I'm a True Believer God at least most of
me is on many a day but not every day
and not all parts of me so can you help
those parts of me that don't totally
believe yet can you can you make up for
that you know I love Jesus doesn't like
push back or like well then you're not a
True Believer you know no no he's like
great he speaks a word
heals the boy
and there you have you know this
language of like believe and Faith you
want me to think of the the passage you
know if you have the faith
um you know
um like you could move a mountain from
you could say be thrown into the sea and
it would happen I mean that's Jesus
right so there's a lot of this kind of
language
um
so however
as James brings up though can you see
where this leads to like eventually a
bit of a crisis
in the sense of
um because remember James is writing
very not hundreds of years after he's
writing like the earliest days of the
Christian faith and we might think well
this was a problem that kicked in later
you know or like now today Christians
are like oh Hypocrites but back in the
early church they were all on fire for
the Lord you know or whatever and
they're in just perfect little saints
um no like here's James writing very
early in the years of Christian faith
and yet already what started to happen
there's these folks who are like we
believe
I believe
right and like they're as Orthodox as
they come they're like oh they believe
in everything about you that whole
Apostles career they're just like yes
and amen you know and yet
if you like lived with them for a week
can't like tell a difference between
them and anyone else
except perhaps that you know they're
like they go to church on Sundays or
whatever
uh can you see where this this leads to
this crisis which is why James he starts
pushing back right he starts asking some
very like hard hitting kind of poignant
questions I would even describe them
they're sort of like he has a few
statements um which I'll read in just a
moment they're kind of uh they're like
wickedly funny if they weren't so tragic
um I love these turns of phrase he um he
says that let's see verse 15.
says suppose a brother sisters without
clothes and daily food if one of you
says to them go in peace I mean can you
just hear the irony in all this like
they're like so hungry like go in peace
be warm and well fed you know the Lord
bless you all of you you know and and
then they just like Usher him out the
door
like
they don't do anything about their
physical needs like and then you ask
this question like what good is it
yeah I believe in Jesus I believe in the
resurrection that's my preacher voice I
don't know I don't really talk about it
a lot but you know oh yeah but but if
but if there's like not actual living
and like an expression
in in like tangible real sacrificial
beautiful ways water
what are we doing I guess we just all
feel real good about ourselves you know
because what we believe and those are
those other people they don't you know
they don't they don't believe and um I
could imagine someone when he gives that
kind of rhetorical that that
hypothetical I can imagine that person
responding but James but I believe and
that's where he goes in verse 19 right
he kind of lists this this kind of very
Orthodox thing it's the idea of
monotheism
um one God you know that's kind of chord
of Judaism it's quarter Christianity
there's one God right uh so he says this
verse 19 you believe there's one God oh
you Orthodox believer you you know you
know all your Doctrine well good I'm
reminded of this is like a drop from
like 15 years ago
um do you remember this audio it came
out of Christian Bale freaking out on
set I think maybe it was Batman I don't
know but the line that came oh good for
you
that's what it is oh good for you
and that's kind of what I hear James
saying you know like you know I believe
in one God oh good for you and what does
he say like even the demons believe that
like oh this I'm getting uncomfortable
uh I want to see what is he getting out
here it seems that there's belief and
then there is belief
right there's belief in this kind of
shallow like yeah I acknowledge X Y and
Z doctrines are true and therefore I'm a
Christian and don't I feel good about
myself you know
um
and then there's like a different kind
of belief it's like a a belief that gets
into every cell of your body
and it oozes out in your living in your
actions in I mean something as tangible
and practical as the way you interact
with every single person that you meet
um I don't I don't say that in like a
pressure way you know of like be perfect
you know but but in this sort of you can
hear the the call of the Christian Life
To Love well is like oh
that's it's a powerful weighty call
the writer as a writer I love Eugene
Peterson
and he passed away about five years ago
and
he uh yeah I think he was really one of
the really the great Christian authors
of our time like most people
um we'll leave a little background for
those unfamiliar so he was a pastor for
like over 30 years
um pastored a number of churches he also
was a prolific author so he wrote like
over 30 books
and
um
I covered all sorts of topics like
discipleship pastoral Ministry uh all
sorts of things like among kind of
pastors he's like quite a legend I think
because he wrote so many books like two
pastors four pastors
um among sort of you know just
Christians he's really known as the guy
who did the message paraphrase of the
Bible that's how he is if you've ever
heard of the message or saying a
preacher and then you know MSG after the
uh for the translation you know in this
case it's a paraphrase not technically
translation but if you've ever struggled
like read the Bible and just like I
can't make sense of this um the message
is a great wonderful paraphrase
um so he was known as like a really a
good man
um but I found myself like a few months
back I started thinking about Eugene
Peterson I started to just kind of
Wonder
um about like what did he do with all of
that money
here's what I mean like so the message
end up selling um I mean this is well
he's a remarkable verse like so he toils
in obscurity for like 30 years
um he's like a pastor church planter
never passed her to church bigger than
500 people so like
you know community churches
and then at age 65 all of a sudden
the message just boom I can't author
before that but he wasn't super well
known the message just boom 17 million
copies of the message around the world
like I'm thinking if he just made one
dollar
for every copy like oh my gosh and we
all know what money can like do to
people no I mean like just the the most
saintly of people and then like get
money and it just it just wrecks you
know folks and so I just started like
doing a little digging you know and like
I couldn't find any interviews we really
talked about it finally I found one guy
who towards the end of his life went to
his house talked with him interviewed
him and asked him kind of around these
these types of questions uh like what
have you learned about money to which
Peterson responded nothing
um which is hilarious nothing and uh the
guy did some digging in later
um so it turns out that basically Eugene
his wife Jan Peterson gave all of their
money away
at the end of his life he lived in his
childhood home
he they had one car a Honda
and they gave it to just I don't know
just Christian organizations missions
people in need they did a lot of two
like academic scholarships funding kids
to go through college education was
really important to him I think he went
on to do at least Masters maybe PhD
level work
um and they just gave it away into the
most beautiful thing about Eugene
Peterson is not simply that he wrote the
message and it's all famous but that he
did what
that he lived the message
he lived the message
that's the call
isn't it that's the invitation
not just to like oh I believe you know I
just it does strike me often I might be
picking up I don't mean to pick on it
I'm certainly not gonna name anyone so
I'm not thinking people here I'm just
thinking of like Christians who are
often the loudest and the most vocal
about what they believe
you know what I mean it's like at times
it just makes me wonder like are you
overcompensating for like you know what
I mean like are you trying to convince
yourself it feels like you're trying to
convince you don't feel confident to me
you know
um
yeah it's about a life lift isn't it
it's about a life lived the longer I
live in religious circles the less
interested I am in people's ideas and
opinions and pet theological beliefs
the more interested I am in how people
live
like like what does it look like and not
in a cookie cutter way where I expect
everyone to I don't know be like be like
me or have my personality or you know
something but like but in a I'm always
curious like how is this good news of
Jesus this love of God that you're
receiving and we sing about you know
like how is that like making its way
into your life and then like shooting
out
coming out sneaking out like how's
what's it looking like you know
um that's the thing I am just curious as
a cat
about I I'm always interested like
um partly because it's always so unique
um to the individual you know I think
it's easy to look at others like oh I
have to live like them you know or
whatever like
um no Jesus always calls us to like it's
it's our own expression of Faith as we
all know it's not enough like thinking
of examples this not enough for a parent
to say like hey I love you to their
kiddo although
message next week will be all about
words and such words do matter
um but we all know if it's only I love
you I love you I love you but there's no
what
there's no like yeah connection action
living expression if they're not present
then it just becomes the cheapest of
talk you know
um we know for friends like hey here for
you here for you
you know but then never really never
hear from them
you know
um
we know something's off in the same way
for us as Christians and we're like oh
Jesus I just love the Lord you know I
believe
um but that love doesn't find its way
in and then out we know
um James asked well good what good what
good is it
there's a an Irish philosopher
Theologian I don't know how well known
he is now he had kind of his Heyday like
10 years ago Peter Rollins is his name
and uh
he is he's great he's a little edgy I
like his early stuff mostly his book
cannot speak of God
excellente
um but he's like he's known as little
edgy partly because he's um Richard Beck
is um another Christian writer who talks
about summertime and wintertime
Christians summertime being like you
know Christians who are just like tend
to be extroverted and just like praise
the Lord kind of people you know what I
mean gotta smile and just like God is
good you know and that's like a
summertime Christian and then there's
wintertime Christians who are you know a
bit kind of down and uh what Richard
Beck points out is um that summertime
Christians tend to emphasize the
resurrection
and winter Christians tend to emphasize
crucifixion you know they feel the
pathos of the world the the crap of the
world and that's the cross you know
they're there for Good Friday you know
um and that's Peter Rollins he is like a
total wintertime Christian so because of
this throughout his career there's been
at times questions about his Orthodoxy
his belief around you know the
resurrection in particular
and so um one day he came out with like
an official statement he put on his blog
he did a video and uh this is what he
said
without equivocation or hesitation just
imagine I'm reading this in an Irish
accent it's he has a great accent I
won't even try that though not even try
um without equivocation or hesitation I
fully and completely admit that I deny
the resurrection of Christ is this
something that anyone who knows me could
tell you I'm not afraid to say it
publicly no matter what some people may
think
I deny the resurrection of Christ every
time I do not serve at the feet of the
oppressed
each day that I turn my back on the poor
I deny the resurrection of Christ When I
close my ears to the cries of the
downtrodden and lend my support to an
unjust and corrupt system
however
there are moments
when I affirm that Resurrection
few and far between
though they may be I affirm it when I
stand up for those who are forced to
live on their knees when I speak for
those who have had their tongues torn
out
when I cry for those who have no more
tears left
to shed
you see
what James is getting at I think in
essence is that
that and we can say I believe
but until that Resurrection Life makes
it deep into us and then actually gets
expressed in the world
what good is it
what good is it you know I guess we just
feel good about our
and so I don't know about you but uh
who I long for the table to be what what
were all each of us in our own way we're
inching towards is is I think this
question
um what does it look like for me to live
it
what does it look like for me to live it
and I think actually that takes a ton of
discernment in wisdom
um
I've been reading recently in Enneagram
book I'll close with this um a book on
the Enneagram and uh one of the
beautiful things about that is the way
it shows that often our natural
inclinations
um
can kind of lead us astray with sort of
an expression of like our false self and
I was thinking um for example I'm an
Enneagram five which means I like to
live in my head
forever I want to think big thoughts and
Dream Big Dreams
and preferably not talk to anyone
um I and in it he's talking about how
fives often he said it's very good for
fives to do something I think in ways
this whole sermon was a sermon to myself
you think I'm preaching to you I'm like
preaching to me and I
um immedly thought of the table I think
starting this community the best thing
I've ever done I hope we've helped some
folks that would be beautiful for me
I needed it I could just be content to
read my books write my e-letters just
send them out onto the internet hey
internet I have ideas farewell do with
it what you may you know I'm just or
just get another degree and there's I'll
just do another degree uh some of you
are like uh school I'm just like yeah
let's do another degree what do you say
you know
um and never enter in to people's lives
right and that's for me that's been the
call it's like Brett get out of your
little room get out of your Ivory Tower
and like enter in
so here's the question right I'm not
saying so that's all of you you're
exactly like that no you are you
and that's where you have to do some
Discerning what does it look like for me
to kind of step outside my comfort zone
and start to serve in love and live in
the ways Jesus is calling me to make
sure I'm not just talking or thinking or
considering you know but living
in the name of the Father the Son the
Holy Spirit
amen
so
as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we
take in the body of Christ in the bread
the blood of Christ in the wine
we do so as people just like that man
from Mark 9 saying I believe Lord help
my unbelief now I'm thinking what that
means at least in my own life is the
action part you know I believe I'm
willing to confess I'll be here Easter
preaching Christ's Resurrection you know
um but God help my unbelief help me to
live it and so kind of my prayer as you
come forward is that you'd be able to
kind of bring yourself and whatever
parts of you are like not really live in
expressing you know you'd bring those to
the table and let God let Christ heal
um what needs to be mended inside you
so um the way we're going to do this is
uh we'll kind of just go row by row so
front row and we'll just work our way
back that way the we found the line at
times can get too long start to happen
so that way we'll just you know row by
row we practice what's called an Open
Table I mean if you're here tonight and
you would like to participate then
regardless of like denominational
affiliation or beliefs you know you just
if you want to connect with Jesus then
you're free to do that you should know
the red is wine the white is grape juice
and then finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like you could take
immediately you can return to your seat
but I'm not going to come back up and
like lead you through the you know the
taking of the elements you can just
um do that on your own
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
in you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
would you stand with us and we're going
to close out with the song called me
higher
I remember when Karen Miner first
introduced me to the song I thought oh
my gosh a worship song that's not about
just our feelings but about actually
putting our feelings into actions
um so it felt very appropriate for this
message as we really are wanting to
apply our faith and the gospel to the
way that we live so you guys sing this
along with us if you want
[Music]
I could just sit and wait for all your
goodness hope to feel your presence
I could just stay
I could just stay right where I am and
hope to feel you hope to feel something
again
[Music]
hold on
I could hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the inside
I could be stable I could be safe here
in your arms and never leave home never
let these walls down but you have called
me higher you have called me deeper and
I'll go where you will lead me Lord
me
[Music]
do you need me
I could hold
I could hold on
I could hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the inside
[Music]
Lord
you will call me
deeper and I'll go where you will live
me
[Music]
you is
you're leading me
you'll Lead Me
I will be yours oh I'll be yours for all
my life
[Music]
foreign
you will call me
[Music]
deeper and I'll go where you
with me
[Music]
Lord you'll leave me
foreign
[Music]
thank you all so much you guys deserve a
standing ovation
[Music]
and the team in the back y'all this
sound team
[Music]
s
there's a lot of work a lot of love
poured into all the things from the
children's classrooms to Brett sermons
to what they're doing up here to what
they're doing in the back a lot of love
to create this space and Brett I am so
thankful for the ways that you walked
out of your little Enneagram five hotel
room
and have given their gifts to the world
and I think
um what Mindy was saying earlier about
just like standing in the confidence of
God's love and really embracing that I
think that's what can move us forward
into doing the things that we're called
to do because it's scary it's scary to
show up in those places that are
vulnerable and unpredictable so I really
do pray this week that we all go into
the week being a little more Brave and a
little more
um ooh maybe unpredictable in that
bravery
um the two announcements I had at the
beginning I'm going to remind you all of
them right now and this QR code is
something you can scan to also look over
them but there is a Counseling Center in
McKinney Texas that is geared towards
lgbtq plus affirming kids adults teens
families and they have a workshop that
they do and it is geared towards
families who have questions or friends
who have questions or misunderstanding
and want to know more and want to
understand more that is a place for them
to show up and to ask all the questions
in a place where those questions are
warranted they are welcomed and um
yeah just a safe place for them not to
offend anyone but to really ask
um what does this look like for me to
love my kid what does this word mean
etc etc now to host that Workshop we
need to see if there's enough interest
in our community for that to happen here
if you are interested in that or if you
know of someone who would be please scan
the QR code and fill out the form under
the queer umbrella and let us know
another thing that we have coming up for
sure is August 27th as a welcome to the
table class so it's all things the table
where we come from who we are what we do
what we want to do and if you're
interested in becoming a member or
learning more about the table you can
sign up again using the QR code and
joining that class on August 27th three
o'clock to 4 30 and there will be child
care
um now then we have a beautiful
benediction and I think in the name of
um oh wait wait wait if you were a
visitor and I see some new faces tonight
and that's so exciting I'm so glad
you're here you already did your one
Brave thing for the week
um there's a table out there with a card
where you can fill out your information
we would love to get to know you hear
your story and just how you got here
because the table brings some really
cool people it's a unique place and
you're probably a unique person so
please fill out that card and let us get
to know you
now the spin addiction I think is
especially beautiful after the um sermon
and after the songs tonight
to just breathe in and go into this week
knowing who you are where you come from
the love that is freely yours to go and
do your thing do God's thing and love
others love yourself and make this world
a better place which we desperately need
so you can take whatever posture you
need you can open your hands you can
close your eyes you can sit but I just
want to speak this over you as we go
into another week
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved
you are worthy
you are accepted
Just As You Are
go
filled with God's holy spirit in the
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
in the name of the Father the Son the
Holy Spirit
peace be with you
amen
if you need prayer or a hug I'll be at
the back and would love to pray with you
hug you high five shake your hand
whatever you need have a great week
thank you
[Music]
the devil be yours oh I will be yours
oh I will be yours for all my life
[Music]
I'll be yourselves
hold me deeper and I'll go away
[Music]
higher you have called me deeper
there are
we return